so day three we actually got into this
um today three we got in the desert so
on day three oh my god oh geez well this
is going horribly wrong just like this
shoot we go hacking about this year and
we're bringing it out into the desert
come on let's go
mike is directing this so you know he's
gonna be figuring out the shot list I
was gonna shoot it and all that kind of
stuff
now why is Mike directing this one
Mike's recognize because well one like a
style movie to those bits for this but
to because we're trying to run a lot of
projects at the same time right now
we can't do everything else and shoot
this the exact same time it helps
actually have something else is pretty
talented behind the camera in this case
Mike and Jan will have that realm cover
both Sam and I do our thing in front of
the camera the Sun so we got involved
with this project because I've known Sam
and Nico for a minute now we've worked
on stuff together like dubstep guns so
they hit me up and asked if I wanted to
do a sweet Mad Max video and I was like
yeah
so day one the magnum opus shows up and
it's a it's a beautiful thing the thing
I'm most excited about is this over here
we have a replica of the car from the
bad max game that's coming out
I think everyone collectively still
refers to is the Interceptor anything
that Mad Max drives called the
Interceptor we've been calling it that
even though that's not its real name so
one thing I was extremely excited for
about this shoot though was somebody
gets the drive this car and it kept
going back and forth it was Niko than me
the Niko than me thankfully it end up is
me I got to drive it oh oh hey little
boy hey little boy you want some sweets
super sweet looking car we strap a
camera onto the hood and we're ready to
pop off the first shots of the day
everybody's like yeah let's do this
and then the car's engine promptly
lights on fire after the second take
long story short I tried to drive it in
automatic and it didn't shift the second
year while I was driving and I was like
revving it was like it's not shifting
just still water snow smoke weed fire
and smoke starts come on oh it's on fire
like it's quick get fire extinguisher by
the way the cameras in the hood so very
first thing is take the camera yeah
we met offseason spire
they could possibly fix the car between
today and tomorrow we then have them fix
a car or we drive a different car we
literally had to change the entire story
originally they weren't supposed to
switch cars from that buggy to the
magnum opus they were supposed to have
the magnum opus the whole time so we had
to change the story on the spot which
was very you know kind of stressful on
top of 150 degree weather and on top of
having a rough shot list at best it was
all kind of disaster town USA so we went
to the house and regrouped so the plan
is to continue forward script unaltered
and then just change it to a dune buggy
does let me ask you the art question
does this make sense
dune buggy again let's look at okay we
ready compare it to the other one I hate
it well you're a great video so you tell
me I hate the blue one less is it any
other option can we get that waistline
we get a vehicle the other one here now
like now to get something out here
tomorrow for sure
might be a Saturday overlap
if I think we're just gonna have another
day to shoot I just don't see how it's
possible that's really I mean this piece
has two parts or three parts it's go to
the camp meet for gas
there's our mission go hit a bunch of
people in the car go back to camp
delivered me so we're gonna go do all
the camp stuff we're gonna do the meet
forecast and deliver the meet and then
tomorrow figure out the car stuff so we
really just ended up focusing on
everything that had no cars in it that
day camera sweet action definitely the
most grueling shoot I've ever ever been
a part of it was really difficult to
think or direct when you're too busy
thinking about how hot and miserable it
is I sound like a total right now
but like trust me when you're out in the
desert and it's 150 degrees and you've
been there like standing outside in the
heat for like hours and hours and hours
it uh it wears you down
people can describe the shots you guys
did right we start day two with this new
plan bright-eyed and bushy-tailed so
this guy Raoul from zombie Patrol was
nice enough to bring out this awesome
dune buggy for us to use so we rewrote
the video around this dune buggy and
around the idea that this thing was kind
of broken down and crappy and so Sam and
Nico needed a new car anyways which
actually ended up working out for the
best I think this is definitely one of
the weirdest videos I've done you're out
in the desert
shooting a Mad Max short thing it is
very hot everyone is very uncomfortable
oh except for Jan who has to be the
contrarian to everything I say when Sam
and Nico came to me with the idea I was
very surprised but it's very dark I
think it's extremely like it's kinda I
don't know it's kind of messed up so in
order to kind of liven things up I
wanted the actual section where they're
hitting people with a car to have more
of a fun upbeat like punk rock kind of
feel so hopefully that lightened the
blow of what they're actually doing if
you're watching this you're in the
future
you already know what happened so why
maybe talking if there's anything you
should take away from this making-of
thing it's that always prepare for the
worst because I mean Murphy's Law and
stay far away from the desert it's a
horrible place of scum and villainy and
I don't think anything should be there I
don't think anything should be shot
there just stay far away from that place
it's a horrible place